non-minimalists
what are the best foods for gut health
now we've talked about a lot of these
things already you've talked about
apple peels you've talked about
blueberries strawberries blackberries
um orange juice i know that you you talk
about
being uh healing and i assume it's
because of
ascorbic acid right yeah um so so those
are some things there
what else what what is what is helpful
for the gut and later during the maximal
i think we'll get into the
the order of operation on things but
let's let's just talk about some foods
that are
that are healing and healthy that we
haven't already touched upon yeah so
assumption is that you are
you are past the point of the inflamed
gut because a lot of the things that are
very healthy for the gut
in an ongoing basis you can't give up
front when you've got all these sort of
issues
so if someone has crohn's disease for
example or or colitis
or ulcers what's healthy for them is
going to be different from what's
healthy for the person
with your average gut it's like you said
there's an order of operations
yeah yeah yeah so they're going to need
aminos and and things like the hmos up
front
and then and then you sort of baby step
your way back into fibers okay yeah okay
but generally speaking um things that
are healthy for the gut
long term would be things like resistant
starch
foods that have phenols so anything with
colors like dark colors in it
let's talk about resistant starches
because i was listening to an interview
you did another podcast
and you had the most hilarious chipotle
hack
yeah um when he goes to chipotle he
he puts ice in the b he gets the beans
separate and puts ice in them
it's a great cove at attention strategy
like if you're if you just spend too
much time alone you just go to chipotle
go to the ice machine and everybody's
like
what are you doing they think oh this
crazy guy's putting
ice in his beans because they've never
seen someone do that but there's a
strategy behind that it's not that you
like cold beans necessarily
it's that they do something different in
the gut uh what other foods are like
that besides
you know the the cold black beans
potatoes okay so potatoes uh
cold potatoes yeah in fact there's a
there are you can look this up there's
potato diets out there where people eat
nothing potatoes and get ripped
yeah on potatoes yeah potatoes with
potatoes do that just generally speaking
garbanzo beans are fantastic probably
the probably like your vegan garbanzos
would be my top of the list because they
have so much protein in them but they
also have
very special long chain carbs in them
that are
very sensitizing for insulin so they're
kind of a wonder food
for um both body fat and for the gut
they're very very effective yeah
but only cold right is that the key well
the difference to think of it is this
way um there's a state
in which certain resistant starches um
don't feed you
they feed the bacteria in their gut and
then there's a state where they feed you
so in one state um a lot of different
kinds of resistant starches when they're
cold or cooled down
the food in them is really not
digestible by you
not all but most of it and you're
feeding the gut
you don't get a lot of energy from it
but when you heat them up those
long-chain starch chains break down into
simple sugars and then it feeds you
gotcha yeah man there's so many things i
want to talk about here on the minimal
before we wrap this up let's talk about
eating in threes really quickly
i found this to be fascinating and since
i've made some changes recently
it's amazing how my satiety is affected
by my previous meal
and it took me 40 years to figure that
out right yeah
talk to me about that yeah well so
there's this really new
fascinating body of research that has to
do with meal to meal sequencing
and it's very science-based and we're
just simply looking at
the effect that a previous meal will
have on the next meal and
and you can look at all these parameters
of the previous meal so you can look at
what was in it
what state was it in how did you combine
it how much time
before the next meal and then based on
all these sort of levers you get all
these different effects at the next meal
so like if i ate celery and cucumbers
for one meal
i might accidentally just gorge on the
next meal
yeah yeah yeah you'll be starving but i
see this with my clients all the time
like talking about like no you know your
choices that you make at one meal
are going to directly impact your next
meal and probably several meals after
that
yes yeah where that gets really
interesting is uh in
in fat loss so what you see a lot in in
active fat loss is
i ate perfectly during the day and i
blew it at night and
very common and the reason is that you
have to set up
the evening in the morning so the things
that and again there's good research on
this like there's research
showing that if you have an egg at
breakfast you're going to have
24-hour total food intake is going to be
slightly less if you have barley
at night you're going to be have much
greater insulin sensitivity in the
morning
if you have a whey protein preload 30
minutes prior to a higher sugar meal
then you're gonna have lower glucose
area under the curve
and so we begin to look at meal to meal
sequencing it's like it's like jiu jitsu
it's like suddenly you have all these
outcomes you can you can produce a good
example would be um peanuts
a small amount of peanuts together with
an orange um as a preload meal you're
gonna eat much less at the next meal
because of the sativity value of both of
those so preload meal will be like 30
minutes
before the the main meal right
you're sort of priming yourself right to
eat less by
it it's almost counterintuitive because
like
well i don't want to eat two meals
within a 45-minute window but it's
actually uh it's almost like an
appetizer in a way
well we've been primed to think that the
only variable in the equation is
calories but but really
sometimes you'll actually increase
calories but but to increase calories
you'll increase
insulin sensitivity and you'll decrease
total food intake
so it's just really thinking along
different lines that's all but it's
power
there's a lot of power in doing it